Je voudrais vous raconter une petite anecdote.
Il y a quelques années, je suis allé voir
un concert du groupe Maroon 5
et les places étaient parties super vite parce que
le groupe était déjà assez connu à l'époque,
il ne faisait qu'une seule date en France et en plus
c'était une petite salle, le Casino de Paris
et le soir du concert, quelqu'un qui
n'avait pas réussi à avoir de place à temps
propose de racheter la mienne pour 200€.
J'avais dû la payer seulement 40€
mais pourtant, j'ai refusé.
Ce qui est bizarre, c'est que si dès le départ
cette place avait été à 200€,
je ne l'aurais jamais achetée, non 200€,
j'aurais trouvé ça trop cher pour ce concert.
Mais du coup, je trouve que cette place ne vaut pas
200€ quand il est question de l'acheter,
mais elle vaut plus que 200€
quand il est question de la vendre.
Je ne serais pas un peu crétin, moi?
[Générique]
La situation que je viens de vous décrire est représentative
de ce que les économistes appellent, l'effet de dotation.
C'est le fait qu'on attribue plus de valeur à une chose
si on la possède que si on ne la possède pas.
Alors soyons clair, mon anecdote,
scientifiquement, elle ne vaut rien,
déjà, c'est juste un cas sur une personne
et il y a plein de bonnes raisons qui peuvent expliquer
que je n'aie pas voulu vendre ma place, même pour 200€.
Je m'étais réjoui à l'avance d'aller au concert,
j'avais fait le déplacement, etc...
Non, une anecdote ce n'est pas de la science.
Mais rassurez-vous, il y a des économistes et des
psychologues qui ont fait des expériences bien contrôlées
pour étudier scientifiquement cet effet de dotation.
Une des expériences les plus intéressantes,
on la doit notamment à Daniel Kahneman, dont j'ai
déjà parlé plusieurs fois dans Crétin de Cerveau.
Kahneman et ses collaborateurs ont réuni un groupe de gens
et à la moitié d'entre eux, pris au hasard,
ils ont donné un mug,
mais pas aux autres.
Et ils ont mesuré à quel prix ceux qui avaient un mug
seraient prêts à le vendre
et dans le même temps, avec ceux qui n'en avaient pas,
ils ont déterminé à quel prix ils seraient prêts à l'acheter.
Résultat: prix de vente moyen
de ceux qui avaient le mug, 5.25$,
mais prix d'achat moyen de ceux
qui ne l'avaient pas, 2.50$,
à peu près la moitié.
C'est-à-dire qu'il se passe dans cette expérience à peu près la même chose que pour moi avec ma place de concert.
Ceux qui avaient le mug lui attribuaient
plus de valeur que ceux qui ne l'avaient pas.
Et là on ne parle pas d'un objet personnel ou d'un truc
auquel ils avaient eu le temps de s'attacher depuis longtemps,
non, on parle d'un simple mug qu'on venait de leur donner.
Ensuite, Kahneman et ses collaborateurs
ont fait une variante de l'expérience.
Ils ont utilisé un autre groupe et d'autres mugs.
Comme dans la première expérience,
à la moitié des gens, ils ont donné le mug
et leur ont demandé à quel prix ils seraient prêts à le vendre.
Et à l'autre moitié, ils ont donné le choix
entre recevoir un mug et recevoir l'argent
en variant le montant pour déterminer à partir de
quelle somme ils préféraient l'argent au mug.
L'estimation moyenne de la valeur du mug
par le premier groupe a été 7$
mais pour le second groupe, seulement 3$.
Il faut bien voir ce que ça veut dire; si on donne le choix
au second groupe entre 5$ et un mug, ils vont prendre 5$,
alors que pour le premier groupe, si on leur propose
de racheter le mug pour 5$, ils vont refuser.
Pourtant c'est exactement la même chose,
les deux groupes, à la fin, ont le choix entre repartir
en ayant un mug ou repartir en ayant 5$.
Oui, sauf que le premier groupe,
on leur avait donné le mug avant.
Cette expérience montre que l'effet
de dotation est puissant et instantané.
Dès que vous possédez quelque chose, vous lui
attribuez plus de valeur que dix secondes auparavant.
Alors, est-ce que c'est vraiment
irrationnel comme comportement?
Et bien, en partie, mais pas complètement.
Pour comprendre ça, on va regarder comment
les économistes analysent le phénomène.
[Générique]
Les économistes comme Kahneman
se sont demandés comment, sur le plan théorique,
on pouvait expliquer l'effet de dotation
et l'explication repose sur deux ingrédients.
Le premier, c'est qu'entre perdre quelque chose
et gagner la même chose,
la perte est toujours plus douloureuse
que le gain n'est agréable.
C'est ce que les économistes appellent
"l'aversion aux pertes".
Et ça ce n'est pas absurde comme comportement,
c'est même assez rationnel.
On va prendre un exemple, la surface de votre logement.
Imaginons que vous viviez dans 40m²
et que ça vous procure un certain niveau de satisfaction.
Si je vous propose 20m² en plus;
votre satisfaction va augmenter.
Puis, encore 20m² de plus; elle augmentera à nouveau,
mais d'une quantité un peu moindre.
Par contre, si je vous propose 20m² en moins
que ce que vous aviez au départ,
là, vous allez vraiment perdre en satisfaction.
Pour la plupart des biens, la courbe de notre satisfaction
n'est pas proportionnelle à la quantité qu'on possède,
elle croît de moins en moins vite.
Les mathématiciens disent qu'elle est concave.
Avec une courbe de satisfaction concave,
c'est parfaitement normal que les pertes
nous impactent plus qu'un gain équivalent,
sauf que dans la vraie vie, on raisonne
rarement de manière absolue,
comme on vient de le faire avec la surface d'un logement.
On raisonne de manière relative.
Par exemple, si je vous propose
d'acheter ce mug pour 5$,
vous allez vous demander si vous vous sentirez
mieux après avoir déboursé 5$ pour l'avoir,
mais vous n'allez pas faire un raisonnement dans l'absolu.
Un raisonnement dans l'absolu, ça serait un truc du genre:
alors, j'ai déjà 7 mugs à la maison et
1669€ sur mon compte en banque;
est-ce que je préfère ça ou bien avoir 1664€
sur mon compte en banque, mais 8 mugs.
Non, on raisonne généralement en relatif,
en analysant les gains ou les pertes
par rapport à une situation de référence.
C'est ce que les économistes appellent
"la dépendance à la référence"
et comme référence, on prend
très souvent la situation actuelle.
Au final, on peut donc expliquer l'effet de dotation
par la combinaison de ces deux ingrédients
dont on vient de parler.
La dépendance à la référence - on juge les choses en relatif -
et l'aversion aux pertes - les pertes paraissent
toujours plus douloureuses que les gains équivalents.
Dans l'expérience de Kahneman,
celui qui n'a pas reçu de mug va se demander
quel plaisir ça va lui apporter d'en avoir un
et celui qui a reçu un mug va prendre ça
comme situation de référence
et va se demander quelle douleur
ça va lui causer de le perdre.
C'est pour ça qu'il va lui attribuer plus de valeur.
Puisqu'on prend souvent comme
référence la situation actuelle,
l'effet de dotation a une conséquence pratique,
il pousse au statu quo.
Celui qui a reçu le mug n'a pas très envie de le vendre
et celui qui ne l'a pas reçu n'a pas très envie de l'acheter.
Mais ce qui est rigolo, c'est que si,
dès le départ, on avait donné le mug à l'autre,
la situation aurait été la même; il y aurait eu statu quo.
D'ailleurs les économistes trouvent parfois
des illustrations grandeur nature et involontaires
de cet effet de statu quo.
Par exemple, dans le New Jersey et
en Pennsylvanie dans les années 90,
il y avait une loi obligeant les conducteurs
à avoir une police d'assurance fournie par l'état
et avec le choix entre deux niveaux de protection :
un niveau pas cher et un niveau plus cher
avec une protection plus élevée.
Dans le New Jersey, par défaut, on avait l'assurance
pas chère et il fallait payer pour avoir l'autre.
Seuls 23% des gens faisaient le changement.
Par contre, en Pennsylvanie c'était le contraire,
par défaut on avait la police d'assurance la plus chère
et 53 % des gens choisissaient de la conserver.
Dans les deux cas, le choix par défaut;
le statu quo paraissait le plus attractif,
alors on imagine assez vite les possibilités
de manipulation commerciale.
Je commence par faire semblant
de vous offrir le mug ou bien une assurance,
du coup ça change votre point de référence,
ça augmente sa valeur à vos yeux
et ensuite j'aurai moins de difficulté
à vous le faire vraiment payer.
Autre possibilité de manipulation offerte
par la dépendance à la référence,
c'est le fait qu'on va juger une situation différemment,
suivant qu'elle nous est présentée
comme un gain ou comme une perte
et un exemple superbe, ce sont
les médailles aux jeux olympiques.
Regardez cette photo,
et on peut en trouver des tas de ce genre,
le médaillé de bronze est super content
et le médaillé d'argent fait la gueule.
Il y en a un qui prend comme référence
le fait qu'il aurait pu être en bas du podium
et qui vit sa médaille de bronze comme un gain
et l'autre qui se dit qu'il aurait pu être champion olympique et qui vit sa médaille d'argent comme une perte.
Présenter les choses comme un gain ou
comme une perte peut modifier les comportements.
Il y a par exemple une étude qui a été faite sur
la manière de présenter leurs bonus à des salariés.
À une partie des gens, on a présenté le bonus
comme un gain, c'est la manière traditionnelle,
si vous atteignez vos objectifs vous aurez une prime,
et à une autre partie, on l'a présenté comme une perte,
c'est-à-dire que le bonus est distribué
d'avance, à titre préventif,
et on vous le reprendra si les
objectifs ne sont pas atteints.
Et devinez quoi, les seconds ont été
plus performants que les premiers.
Après, niveau stress au travail,
je ne suis pas sûr de l'apport.
Autre exemple d'une manière de présenter
une chose comme un gain ou comme une perte.
Qu'est-ce que vous préférez? Une augmentation
de salaire de 2% sachant que l'inflation est de 3%,
ou bien une diminution de votre salaire
de 1% sachant qu'il n'y a pas d'inflation.
Bien sûr que vous savez pertinemment
que c'est la même chose
mais en votre for intérieur, vous ne trouvez pas quand
même que la première solution est un peu moins douloureuse ?
Rassurez-vous, même les économistes professionnels
se font avoir par ce genre de manipulations.
Il y a une expérience intéressante qui a été faite.
Pour l'inscription à une conférence d'économie,
les participants devaient payer des frais d'inscription
et puis comme souvent, pour faciliter l'organisation,
le prix était moins cher si on
s'inscrivait suffisamment tôt.
A la moitié des gens, au moment de s'inscrire sur
le site internet, on présentait ça comme une réduction,
c'est-à-dire, prix d'inscription 195$ mais réduction
de 50$ si jamais on s'inscrit avant une certaine date.
Pour l'autre moitié, c'était présenté
comme une augmentation;
prix de 145$ mais avec une pénalité
de 50$ si on s'inscrit après une certaine date.
Dans le premier cas, 67% des participants
seulement se sont inscrits en avance
alors que dans le deuxième cas 93%.
C'est-à-dire que la menace de l'augmentation du prix
a été bien plus forte que la promesse de la réduction
et pourtant les deux prix étaient exactement les mêmes.
Cette idée que la référence réelle ou perçue
joue un rôle sur nos prises de décision
a notamment été évoquée au sujet
du principe de la détention provisoire.
Si vous êtes en détention provisoire,
vous serez peut-être plus enclins
soit à plaider coupable, soit à essayer
de négocier un compromis
parce que vous verrez ça comme
un moyen de regagner votre liberté,
alors que si vous n'êtes pas en détention provisoire, peut-être que vous vous battrez plus pour prouver votre innocence
parce que vous verrez ça comme
un moyen de préserver votre liberté.
C'est-à-dire que la détention provisoire en fait,
change le point de référence
et donc change le comportement.
[Générique]
En plus des exemples que j'ai déjà donnés,
le principe du point de référence
ne va pas simplement servir à présenter
un gain comme une perte ou vice-versa
mais aussi à moduler la valeur,
à nos yeux, d'un gain ou d'une perte.
Par exemple, Daniel Kahneman a soumis
des sujets à l'expérience suivante.
Vous achetez dans un magasin une veste
qui coûte 125$ et une calculatrice qui coûte 15$
et le caissier sympa vous informe que dans un autre
magasin de l'enseigne situé un peu plus loin,
ils bradent la calculette pour seulement 10$.
Est-ce que vous faites le déplacement?
Réponse: oui à 68%.
Pareil pour un deuxième groupe, mais cette fois c'est
la veste dont le prix est un peu plus bas dans un autre magasin;
120$ seulement.
Est-ce que vous faites le déplacement?
Réponse: oui à seulement 29 %.
Pourtant c'est le même problème, regardez bien,
dans les deux cas on en a pour 140$ au total
et on nous propose de faire un déplacement pour gagner 5$,
sauf que dans le premier cas, on juge les 5$
comparativement au prix de 15$ de la calculatrice
et on trouve ça intéressant,
alors que dans le second cas, on juge les 5$
comparativement au prix de 125$ de la veste
et on se dit que ça ne vaut pas le coup.
Autre exemple pour illustrer ce genre de phénomène,
mais avec des pertes cette fois.
Imaginons que vous décidez d'aller voir
une pièce de théâtre et la place coûte 10€.
Vous avez acheté le ticket à l'avance et, arrivé à l'entrée
du théâtre, vous vous rendez compte que vous l'avez perdu.
Est-ce que vous la rachetez pour 10€ ou est-ce que
vous laissez tomber l'idée d'aller voir la pièce?
et bien dans l'expérience seulement
46% des gens rachètent le ticket.
Et comme toujours, on a un deuxième groupe
et on le soumet à une situation légèrement différente.
Vous décidez d'aller voir une pièce de théâtre
mais vous n'avez pas acheté de ticket à l'avance
et arrivé à l'entrée du théâtre, vous remarquez que
vous avez perdu un billet de 10€ dans votre portefeuille.
Est-ce que vous achetez quand même votre place de théâtre?
Réponse: oui à 88%.
Je vous laisse vous convaincre que, financièrement
parlant, il s'agit bien de la même situation.
Dans les deux cas, on a perdu 10€ et il s'agit de payer
10€ pour pouvoir aller voir la pièce de théâtre.
Sauf que dans le deuxième cas,
on a simplement perdu 10€,
alors que dans le premier cas on juge
la perte de 10€ par rapport à une référence;
le prix de notre ticket et donc psychologiquement,
on a l'impression que le prix de la place double.
Je voudrais finir sur un dernier exemple
assez spectaculaire du rôle de la référence
et qui va me servir de transition avec
le prochain épisode de Crétin de Cerveau.
Imaginons, vous venez d'attraper un virus dont
on vous dit qu'il est mortel dans 0.1% des cas;
c'est-à-dire 1 cas sur 1000.
Heureusement, il existe un vaccin qui peut vous en protéger.
Combien seriez-vous prêt à mettre
pour acheter ce vaccin?
Réponse typique obtenue: 200$.
Autre situation maintenant.
Vous êtes en bonne santé et on vous propose
de participer à un test clinique d'un nouveau vaccin.
Le seul hic, c'est qu'il y a un risque de 0.1%
pour que le test se passe mal et que vous mouriez.
Combien vous demanderiez en compensation
pour accepter de participer au test?
Réponse typique obtenue: 10000$.
Et pourtant encore une fois,
les deux situations sont assez analogues.
Dans les deux cas, il s'agit de mettre une valeur
monétaire sur un risque de 0.1% de mourir.
Sauf que dans le premier cas,
la référence est qu'on a déjà chopé le virus,
alors que dans le deuxième cas,
la référence est qu'on est en bonne santé
et donc dans le premier cas, si on meurt,
c'est en quelque sorte par omission,
alors que dans le deuxième cas,
c'est par action volontaire.
Du coup, psychologiquement,
ce n'est quand même pas la même chose.
Est-ce que c'est vraiment irrationnel de se comporter
très différemment dans ces deux situations?
Je vous laisse vous faire votre opinion
et de toute façon on reviendra sur ces questions
dans le prochain épisode de Crétin de Cerveau
qui parlera de la manière dont on évalue les risques.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, comme toujours
n'hésitez pas à la partager si elle vous a plu
pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne.
Vous pouvez retrouver les actualités de la chaîne
sur Facebook et sur Twitter
et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent
me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Merci, à bientôt.
Sous-titres: Warteks